okay well most people number one they
get up in the morning
they check their cell phone they check
their text their whatsapp their
facebook they post something on facebook
drive to work the same way do the same
thing so
they're in a program they've actually
lost their free will to the program wow
so if you start your day and you start
your day with this simple question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
you ask yourself that question now
listen your body's gonna go like well
you got to get a cup of coffee and you
got to get
it i'm tired yeah and you got to go ah
body
uh you're not the mind i'm the mind
right now you're going to sit here i'm
going to feed you
you're going to get your coffee you're
going to do all those things but right
now
this is my time you're going to obey me
right
so now the body's no longer the mind
you're the mind and so when it wants to
get up and you become aware of it
and return back to the present moment
every time you do that's a victory
and you're changing some aspect of
yourself so then
ask yourself i do this all the time
write down four thoughts
that you're going to stay conscious of
the whole day i can't it's too hard
you'd be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day
for weeks on end write down what you
speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act
how do you how do you act you complain
you blame you make excuses you feel
sorry for yourself
that's a victim consciousness what
emotions do you live by is it possible
that you're so used to living by guilt
you don't even know it's guilt it just
feels like you
do you allow your energy to drop become
conscious of those states of mind and
body and review them
and say this is the old self then say
what thoughts do i want to fire and wire
in my brain and start firing and wiring
and start feeling it
what behaviors will i demonstrate today
what choices will i make one day one
lifetime
just like you did rehearse them rehearse
the whole entire thing
begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain
and if you keep installing it the
hardware is going to become a software
program you're going to start thinking
and acting that way
and then here's the tough part can you
teach
your body emotionally what your future
is going to feel like before it's made
manifest
and don't get up until you feel that way
now practice that for a few days
and then see if you can stay in that
state and watch
all of a sudden all those weird doors
start opening for you synchronicities
synchronicities whatever they are number
two
take up time at the end of your day the
end of your day before you lay down
and give thanks for your life and feel
gratitude
and really teach your body what it feels
like
the emotional signature of gratitude
when gratitude means
you're getting something if i give you
something that's of value
you would say thank you because you
would feel it right so when you're
receiving you're giving thanks so
gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving so
then
people only accept believe and surrender
to the thoughts equal to their emotional
state
so if you're in a state of gratitude
every thought is going to make it right
down into your body
if you're saying i'm i'm healthy i'm
healthy i'm healthy i'm wealthy and
wealthy and wealthy and your body's
programmed the negativity it's saying no
you're not no you're not knowing that i
thought it's going to stop right here
so as you elevate your state there are
about
1200 different chemical reactions that
go on in the body to begin to restore
and repair the body in a state of
gratitude
and so we've done the research to prove
that 10 minutes
and just feel it with all of your heart
that's it third thing and
and very important take time
whenever it is sit down close your
eyes and begin to just open your
awareness
to the space around you and just sense
it and pay attention to it and become
more aware of it
the act of opening your awareness begins
to reduce the stress hormones
and creates more coherent brainwave
states i'm doing it right now
it's just a practice it's just a
practice
the more you do it the better you get it
i want to explain
something to you that not many people
really understand i want to talk about
the law
of attraction do you know that the law
of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go
it's going to go down it's never going
to go back up it's going to go down
that is the law of gravity anything
heavier than earth is attracted towards
the center of the world
well the law of attraction is always
working now
how does it work well i use a diagram
to explain the mind now let this circle
represent your mind and let
this little circle here represent your
body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment your
body is a molecular structure this is a
massive energy
and a very high speed of vibration if
you looked at your body through a
microscope
you'd see that energy dancing right
before your eyes
and here's something that'll keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it
the body does not stop moving if you go
to a funeral parlor
and pick up the remains and look at it
you will see it moving
and if it wasn't moving how would it
ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up and it's how you use your mind
that's going to dictate the vibration
you're in now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind now this
subconscious mind has been programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was
go just like this subconscious mind wide
open
and everything that was going on around
it went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby
form something called a paradigm
now a paradigm is information
it's a multitude of habits you are the
product of your environment
but prior to that you are the product of
a genetic strain that goes back for
generations
now i'm going to say that the paradigm
is
x type energy now you've got the ability
here on a conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas there's
a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops
it flows to and through you you can
actually photograph this power leaving
you
it flows to and through you now as it
flows in
you will start thinking and you'll
probably think x-type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce x type results now
it's the results you want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe
everything vibrates nothing rests we
live in a notion of motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind
that control the vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act
but it also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you
you attract people that are in harmony
with you you see everything operates on
frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does
and the only music you can attract is
the music
that is tuned in to the vibration you're
in now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking but that
doesn't do anything you've got to change
the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens now
talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in
and that dictates what you attract so if
you keep attracting what you don't want
understand this it's the paradigm that's
causing the problem
you can think a y type thought which is
totally different than the x type
conditioning
it isn't going to go anywhere because
when you go to get emotionally involved
and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type thon the paradigm
will kick it out
you know why it's so uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this the paradigm and the
thinking control the vibration you're in
and the vibration is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind
and you can gather all kinds of
information have you ever wondered why
some people have such an educated mind
they have degrees coming right off the
end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm the law of attraction
you've got to change this you've got to
change the vibration you're in
and your whole world changes listen in
1961
a man gave me this book and he said do
exactly what i tell you
he was giving me y-type ideas it caused
an enormous amount of discomfort but i
did exactly what he said
and you know something my income went
from 4 000 to 175
000 in a year and then i took it over a
million it took me
nine and a half years to figure out what
happened
this is what i'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here when
the paradigms change your life changes
it's a beautiful concept it's an
absolutely phenomenal concept
now you know why you're getting the
results you're getting it has nothing to
do with your intellect
your intellect you can figure out how to
do things that doesn't mean you're going
to do them
you'll hear people say i believe that
but their behavior would indicate
they've never even heard of it
why we believe something on a conscious
level
on a subconscious level the paradigm
believes something else
there's a word called praxis praxis is
the integration of belief with behavior
we've got to take the beliefs that we
have consciously that we determine by
thinking and plant them in the place of
the old belief
see i used to believe that i couldn't do
anything better than i was doing
i felt fortunate that i was on the fire
department
the idea of building a company that
operated all around the world furthest
thing from my mind
but you know something as i changed my
paradigm my whole world changed
that's what we do that's what it's all
about
you've got to change your paradigm if
you want to change your life
now you can study all you want if you
don't gain an understanding how to alter
that program
and that's what the paradigm is it's a
program it's a multitude of concepts
that are fixed in your subconscious mind
that literally control your behavior
it's a beautiful concept to understand
it's a terrible one if you don't
understand it because it literally
controls your life
why do you think most people go right
through their life and keep getting the
same results year after year after year
well it's just the way it is and they
don't know
we should be taught this in school but
we're not
how was the paradigm formed through the
repetition of information
how's the paradigm change repetition of
information
now let's suppose you're having a
difficult time with money
you find that you've got more going out
than coming in
you've got to change your concept about
money how do you do
that through the repetition of an idea
that's where affirmations comes in
i'll give you one i've been using for
years i am so happy and grateful now
that money comes to me in increasing
quantities
through multiple sources on a continuous
basis
i am so happy and grateful now that
money comes to me
in increasing quantities through
multiple sources on a continuous basis
you don't just say that once or twice
you've got to repeat that maybe a
thousand times a day every day for maybe
90 days
and you'll start to change your whole
concept about money
wealthy people all have multiple sources
of income
now i'm going to tell you what happened
to me i drove around with a battery
operated record player
and a long playing record and i played
it
over and over again every day for
probably a couple of years
this was so totally illogical it was
behavior
everybody thought i was losing it and
i'm reading the same book
every day think and grow rich as a
matter of fact i'm still reading the
same book
and it was the repetition of earl
nightingale's information
and the book that changed the paradigm i
didn't know what i was doing
i didn't understand what i was doing but
i did it
do you know i had a man come up to me in
the waldorf hotel
in new york waldorf at the end of a
three-day program and he said bob i
really want to thank you
for what you've just given to me he said
for the first time in my life i've
understood how i accomplished what i did
i said what did you do he said i won the
gold medal
in the decathlon in the olympics in
melbourne australia
in 1957 that's right
milt campbell and he said i never
understood how he did it
he said the next time you run a seminar
i want to bring my boys and he did
milton and i became great friends in
fact milt has a key to our house
he can come stay there any time he wants
i live in toronto he's in new jersey
but here was the top athlete the world a
very best athlete in the world he didn't
understand how he got there
most people that are very accomplished
cannot tell you why they are
that's why they are they've rewritten
the program they changed the paradigm
they might not have understood how they
did it
but they did it that's what our company
is all about we teach people how to
change paradigms
i want to thank you for watching this
but i'm going to ask you
to share it with other people share it
with them say come and watch this
start a rapport build a rapport with
people you know
it's a great way to live and this is
great information to understand
thanks for listening it's bob proctor i
enjoy sharing it with you
obviously you knew somewhere inside
yourself that you were destined to be
famous because i think it's a really a
marvelous thing that visualization thing
you did
john do you read about this or hear this
that you used to go up on mulholland
drive and park
every night and visualize seeing
yourself as yeah i would visualize
uh yeah this is when you were broken
right having
directors interested in me and people
that i respected uh
um saying you know i like your work or
whatever that is and
and uh i would visualize things coming
to me that i
wanted or whatever this was in like 1987
85 yeah
and i had nothing at that time so it was
like but it just made me feel better it
made me at that time
all it really was for me was kind of
making me feel better i would drive home
and think well i do have these things
and they're out there i just don't
have a hold of them yet but they're out
there okay so you would get this from
what self-help books or whatever
yeah uh-huh self-help section self-help
section they've renamed it the jim
carrey
wing so didn't you write yourself a
check
i heard that you did is that true i
wrote myself a check for 10 million
dollars
for acting services rendered and i gave
myself
uh five years or three years maybe
and uh and i dated at thanksgiving 1995.
and i put it in my wallet and i kept it
there and it deteriorated and
deteriorated and stuff
and uh and uh but then
just before thanksgiving 1995 i found
out that i was going to make
10 million dollars on i think it was
dumb and dumber maybe dumb and dumber
yeah
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want to learn how to attract
success
into your life check out the video right
there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there